this is a really weird move because you
might give your kings some space but the
back rank isn't really a concern and
actually you deprive a key Square for
your pieces often the queen can float
the H3 square
a rook can float there this is actually
a impedes the Y position often you push
this Pawn Yeah whole way forward
um initia I mean this is basically like
you said you mentioned the C3 Sicilian
it's basically a transposition to some
of those lines it's a caracon but you're
one tempo up as white and uh it's also
similar to a line of the of the slav but
you just drop your Bishop back that's
the main move and you basically have the
same position as you do in the game but
you've got an extra time you've got
extra time because you saved on this
really useless move so it's actually
totally inexplicable by the way this
move it's in my opinion this is a like
if you ask Anish what after the game
what is H3 let's say he's in a good mood
and he wants to talk H3 is just you know
what he wants to do Lawrence for example
if black